it's time for et's social study yard  quick look at what the stars are posting  online still silly he and Shirin might  just be the newest Spice Girl he teamed  up with a baby spice for a duet of  goodbye while dancing Pro Maksim  Chmerkovskiy shared this sweet photo and  captioned it it's been a one-week plus  one day of my fatherhood and I'm the  happiest person that's ever lived and  new mom Candice Swanepoel stunned in a  bikini posing with her baby just three  months after giving birth someone asked  me today what my celebrity crush was and  I really don't think there's anyone  hotter Miley Cyrus wished the quote  happiest birthday ever - my favorite  being ever ever ever her fiance Liam  Hemsworth  then there's Bella Hadid who showed off  a little side boob on Instagram it's  good and over on Twitter Janelle Monae  and Evan Rachel Wood had a total love  fest over each other  [Music]